[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und anne gellinek
guten abend wir beginnen mit einer
hoffnungsvollen nachricht aus dem
ukraine krieg das im juli ausgehandelte
abkommen über die ausfuhr von getreide
aus ukrainischen häfen hält die
vereinten nationen und die türkei hatten
die deal mit russland und der ukraine
vermittelt 27 schiffe sollen die ukraine
inzwischen verlassen haben da aber
niemand weiß wie lange russland
frachtschiffe fahren lässt sucht die
ukraine fieberhaft nach alternativ
routen um ihr getreide auf den weltmarkt
zu bringen eine davon führt über
rumänien wo eine eingerostete bahnlinie
nun wieder zur lebensader wird wolf
christian ullrich berichtet
die achsen ächzen unter der
tonnenschweren last dies ist der erste
zug der getreide aus der ukraine nach
rumänien bringt in den hafen von balázs
6000 tonnen weizen werden hier in den
kommenden tagen auf schiffe weiter
verlauten
wir sind hocherfreut an diesem
historischen tag dabei zu sein dies ist
das erste mal nach 15 jahren das auch
diesen gleisen ein zug rollt im
angesicht des krieges öffnen wir eine
neue route für das getreide
die neue route führt auf der donau zum
schwarzmeerhafen konstanzer und von dort
aus in die welt alles hing bis jetzt
davon ab diese vier kilometer gleis mit
ukrainischer spurweite wieder in gang zu
setzen die bis in den rumänischen hafen
reichen die aber ungenutzt vor sich hin
rotten das ist jetzt gelungen
wir planen das zunächst 100 weitere
waggons nach graz kommen ukrainische
unternehmen haben jetzt einen neuen weg
nach europa
die rumänischen häfen sind für räder
sichere gewässer deshalb ist die
hoffnung groß nun eine neue route für
das getreide gefunden zu haben das
ergänzt auch die bemühungen der
vereinten nationen mit dem dringend
benötigten weizen eine hungerkatastrophe
zu verhindern in odessa legte gestern
ein getreide frachter des
welternährungsprogramms an
dieses schiff wird 23.000 tonnen weizen
zu hungrigen menschen in den kopien
bringen menschen die am rande des
hungers stehen
[Musik]
wenn die frachter das schwarze meer
verlassen werden sie am bosporus
kontrolliert und koordiniert
un-generalsekretär ich war heute in
istanbul vor ort und forderte mehr
solcher ausfuhren von getreide und
düngemitteln aus der ukraine und aus
russland um die rohstoff märkte zu
beruhigen
die playoffs ich war sehr gerührt ein
schiff des welternährungsprogramms
richtung afrika zu sehen das ist von
großer wichtigkeit für die menschheit
die
hoffnung sterbe zuletzt sagte er noch
dies müsse ein erster schritt richtung
frieden seien der getreideexport bleibt
mühsam es läuft längst noch nicht alles
rund im hafen von ganzen bauen sie
zumindest einen neuen kai um in zukunft
noch mehr getreide aus der ukraine in
die welt zu verschiffen
aus teheran ist uns jetzt unser türkei
korrespondent jörg brase zugeschaltet
jörg die türkei versucht ja eine
vermittlerrolle einzunehmen im konflikt
zwischen russland und der ukraine
was verspricht sich der türkische
präsident erdogan eigentlich davon
nun erdogan braucht gute nachrichten für
sein wahlvolk zu hause und diese guten
nachrichten die bekommt natürlich am
besten über gute geschäfte erdogan hatte
am anfang des konflikts ja schon gesagt
dass sich die türkei wirtschaftlich es
sich nicht leisten kann es sich mit der
einen oder mit der anderen seite zu
verscherzen russland ist der größte
energielieferant der türkei türkische
banken hören wir haben sie mit
russischen banken nun auf ein russisches
bezahlsystem geeinigt mit dem man die
rechnungen begleichen will außerhalb von
swift von dem russland jahr
ausgeschlossen ist die türkei macht
rüstungsdeals mit russland und das macht
man auch mit der ukraine und die ukraine
ist eben auch der größte getreide
lieferant für die türkei man muss sich
vorstellen dass ein viertel aller
schiffe die jetzt im rahmen dieses
getreide abkommens von der ukraine
losfahren konnten dass ein viertel
dieser schiffe in der türkei letztlich
geleucht gelöscht wurden das heißt die
türkei profitiert massiv von dem deal
sind sie auch selbst mitverhandelt sie
beobachten für uns in teheran ja auch
die verhandlungen um die wiederbelebung
des iranischen atom abkommens seit tagen
hören wir dass eine einigung kurz bevor
steht woran hängt es
das hängt daran dass dieser kompromiss
auf dem man sich geeinigt hat und auf
dem wir nun auch wirklich schon viele
monate warten dass dennoch abgelegt
werden muss politisch abgelegt werden
muss in washington und in teheran ist
hing wie mir hören also an einigen
technischen details auf die man sich
geeinigt hat in die einzelheiten will
ich gar nicht einstellen ist ging um die
aufhebung der sanktionen schrittweise es
geht um die wiedereinführung des
kontrollsystems der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde
man hat einen kompromiss gefunden und
das interesse auf beiden seiten ist im
moment denke ich relativ groß iran
möchte sein öl wieder offiziell
verkaufen dürfen und möchte an das
internationale bankensystem
angeschlossen werden und die europäer
wollen dass irgendwann mal wieder bis zu
50 millionen barrel iranisches öl auf
den weltmarkt kommen um vor dem
hintergrund der energiekrise die preise
zu senken der politische druck denke ich
der ist aber hier in teheran geringer wo
man solches abkommen abzunicken als in
washington denn da musste man einsehen
dass der ausstieg aus dem atom abkommen
und die sanktionen gegen iran komplett
kontraproduktiv waren ziel war ja mal
iran vom bau der bombe abzuhalten und
das regime in teheran zu schwächen und
den beiden fällen hat man das genaue
gegenteil erreicht danke jörg brase in
teheran für diese analyse
sollen russische touristen in venedig
prosecco trinken dürfen während ihr
präsidentin der ukraine einen brutalen
krieg führt oder ist es vielmehr
ungerecht russische andersdenkende nun
auch noch aus europa auszusperren die
diskussion über ein eu einreiseverbot
für russische bürger nimmt fahrt auf
länder wie tschechien lettland oder
estland sind vorgeprescht und schränkten
die vergabe von visa bereits im
alleingang ein der russische
verteidigungsminister schoigu
kritisierte mögliche einreiseverbote als
so wörtlich nazi politik alexander pohl
beginnt seinen bericht an der estnisch
russischen grenze
nach war ganz im nordosten ist lanz die
drittgrößte stadt des landes liegt
direkt an der grenze zu russland und ist
für viele russen das tor zur
europäischen union mit einem estnischen
touristenvisum ausgestattet überqueren
hier täglich über 2000 russen die grenze
doch seit donnerstag wird das visum
nicht mehr akzeptiert
ich kann damit jetzt nicht mehr nach
russland einreisen und das bedeutet auch
dass eine einreise in den schengen raum
sehr schwierig
im februar hatte die eu ihren luftraum
für russische flugzeuge gesperrt wer aus
russland in die eu möchte dem bleibt
bislang die flugverbindung über die
türkei oder der landweg über finnland
und das baltikum doch immer mehr länder
in europa wollen jetzt dem beispiel
irlands folgen und russischen
staatsbürger die einreise verweigern
auch finnland
geht es noch war ich denke es ist nicht
richtig dass russische staatsbürger in
europa herumreißen können während
russland in der ukraine menschen tötet
das ist falsch
und so war das nordisch deutsche treffen
zu beginn der woche geprägt von der
debatte auf welcher seite die russische
bevölkerung steht und ob sie kollektiv
verantwortung trägt für den krieg in der
ukraine der
gestrenge reisebeschränkungen für russen
wir haben den europäischen luftraum
gesperrt ich finde es gut dass wir über
maßnahmen diskutieren aber es ist nicht
alles schwarz
nicht schwarz oder weiß bundeskanzler
scholz drückt es so aus nicht alle
russen seien unterstützer von putin
es gibt viele menschen die aus russland
fliehen weil sie mit dem russischen
regime nicht einverstanden sind die
entscheidungen die wir treffen sollten
es diesen menschen nicht schwerer machen
die eu kommission lehnt ein
grundsätzliches reiseverbot für alle
russischen bürger ab über vieles andere
könne man reden aber
wichtig ist dass alle schritte die
unternommen werden gemeinsam erfolgen
und unsere sanktions ziele unterstützen
anfang september wird sich die
kommission mit dem thema visa vergabe
erneut befassen
im ukraine krieg wird weiter gekämpft
doch bleibt die lage unübersichtlich
damit beginnen die nachrichten von dir
gundula aus dem verteidigungsministerium
in moskau heißt es bei den russischen
angriffen in der region hartz iv sei
mehr als 100 ukrainische kämpfer getötet
worden nach angaben aus kiew sind bei
den jetzt sieben zivilisten ums leben
gekommen
vielerorts habe man die russischen
angriffe erfolgreich abgewehrt die
ukraine und russland werfen sich
weiterhin gegenseitig beschuss nahe des
atomkraftwerks sei faurecia vor diese
seltenen aufnahmen aus dem akw sollen
russische militärfahrzeuge zeigen der
ukrainische präsident zielinski hat in
seiner videoansprache russland
erpressung auf dem energiesektor
vorgeworfen mit der geplanten
unterbrechung der gaslieferungen durch
nord stream 1 wolle russland probleme in
europa schaffen in deutschland geht die
debatte über entlastungen weiter der dgb
fordert spürbare maßnahmen für alle die
union unterstützung für energieintensive
unternehmen und die grünen setzen auf
zielgenauere hilfen für
einkommensschwache am tag der offenen
tür der bundesregierung hat
finanzminister lindner seine forderung
nach steuersenkungen bekräftigt bei
einem bürgerdialog erklärte er mit
hinweis auf die pläne für wohngeldreform
und bürgergeld auch für menschen mit
geringen einkommen werde etwas getan
auch morgen stehen die ministerien offen
nach den vorwürfen der vetternwirtschaft
und vorteilsnahme beim rbb haben die
intendantinnen und intendanten der ard
denn nun amtierenden spitze des
rundfunks berlin-brandenburg das
vertrauen entzogen ard-chef buhrow
erklärte mit dieser geschäftsleitung
werde die aufarbeitung nicht zügig
gelingen zuvor hatte heute auch die
vorsitzende des rbb rundfunkrates ihr
amt niedergelegt
heftige unwetter haben in teilen
deutschlands zu überschwemmungen und
behinderungen auf den verkehrswegen
geführt besonders betroffen dortmund der
hauptbahnhof wurde durch einen unwetter
schaden am stellwerk lahmgelegt bei
obersdorf direkt am alpenrand brachten
die wassermassen einen hang zum rutschen
und nach den kurzfristigen starkregen in
einigen regionen wird das wetter nun
wieder überwiegend freundlich ein paar
schauer gibt es an der nordsee sowie von
ostsachsen bis ins östliche bayern bei
22 bis 28 grad am montag ganz im osten
dienstag im nordwesten etwas regen sonst
trocken viel sonne und wieder steigende
temperaturen bis 32 grad
fehle noch die gewinnzahlen vom lotto
sie lauten ohne gewähr 12 19 26 32 36 40
superzahl 1 weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 6
die european championships biegen auf
die zielgerade ein morgen ist der letzte
wettkampftag in münchen für die
deutschen athleten athleten war es ein
heimspiel und zwar ein sehr
erfolgreiches 21 mal gold für
deutschland platz eins im
medaillenspiegel
ob das so geblieben ist weiß aris
donzelli
die antwort geben diese bilder und damit
ja der meyer finale im 3000 meter
hindernislauf sie gewinnt über russians
silber wo kann da liter beres tanz ins
glück ebenfalls silber im stabhochsprung
mit übersprungenen 5 meter 85 an einem
tag mit zwei mal gold fünfmal bronze und
eben zweimal silber für das deutsche
team
im regen geht es am vormittag durch
münchen 20 kilometer sagt feige gewinnt
die erste deutsche medaille des tages
bronze hinter der polin die antigone und
rissen pilot der aus griechenland
gewinnt diesen kraftakt
umjubelt die kanuten auf der
regattastrecke oberschleißheim sebastian
brendel ist schon 34 jahre alt aber
hungrig auf erfolge im einer-canadier
erwartet er sich nach fünf kilometern im
endspurt gegen adolf balasz aus ungarn
gold sein 15 bei europameisterschaften
zu viert flügen sie durchs wasser der k4
über 500 meter ist unwiderstehlich gold
für max rendschmidt tom liebscher jakob
schopf und max lemke
paulina paszek links und julia hacke
holen über 500 meter bronze erst ein
jahr sitzen sie im selben boot belgien
gewinnt silber gold geht an polen
aus zehn metern ins wasser synchron
elegant die geschwister christina und
elena wachsen überzeugen die
kampfrichter in rom und gewinnen bronze
in der münchner rudi sedlmayer halle
gibt es trotz halbfinal-niederlagen zwei
deutsche bronzemedaillen weil der dritte
platz nicht ausgespielt wird sabine
winter unterliegt nach großem kampf der
österreicherinnen portanova
und im deutschen duell verliert gegen
nina mittelham die morgengold im blick
hat
auch bei den herren ist mindestens
silber für deutschland möglich dank dem
25 jahre alten dank chu er gewinnt das
halbfinale gegen den schweden feiert mit
3 zu 1 und erreicht das finale gegen die
slowenen dario jerkic
das wars vom sport und auch von uns für
heute und noch viel mehr sport geht zum
gleichen sportstudio mit dunja hayali
uns beide gibt es morgen wieder einen
schönen abend und tschüss
[Musik]